[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est par le critérium de la première
neige à valdiser qu'a débuté la saison
internationale de ski il s'agit là de
l'une des premières mises en train pour
les champions à la veille des Jeux
Olympiques c'est donc pour eux la saison
de qui commence et particulièrement pour
les Français le meilleur de tous les
Français c'est michelpin qui termine 2è
de l'épreuve sous l'œil d'un connaisseur
[Applaudissements]
gu le vainqueur le voici c'est
l'Américain Bud
Werner par sa victoire il rappelle fort
opportunément à tous les Européens qu'il
pourrait bien jouer les 3è larons aux
Jeux Olympiques
d'inbr Werner un visage qu'on verra
souvent à l'arrivée des grandes épreuves
ce premier échec des Français à valdiser
n'a pas entamé leur optimisme cette
année ils misent tout sur les Jeux
Olympiques Honoré Bonnet leur entraîneur
conseil spoulin voici entre autres
Jean-Claude kil Honoré Bonnet et
pa ils sont tous cela et tous préparent
l'avenir en s'entraînant d'arrachepied
l'entraînement d'ailleurs commence au
chalet par le fartage et la vérification
du
matériel
et puis chaque jour on prend le chemin
des
[Musique]
pentes c'est modui qui ouvre la
piste je succède il est jeune et il a
bien du mal à freiner son tempérament et
voilà Kili retiendra sans doute la
leçon mais le numéro 1 de l'équipe de
France c'est toujours gu Pera c'est sur
lui que se porte une grande partie des
ambitions et des espoirs de l'équipe de
France qui est prête à remporter
d'éclatant succès à hsbruck en tout cas
quels que soient les résultats d'insbru
on ne pourra pas dire que les français
n'auront pas pris au sérieux les Jeux
olympiques
[Musique]
d'hiver à quelques semaines du tournoi
des S nation l'équipe de France de rugby
a complètement manqué son examen de
passage au Stadium Municipal de Toulouse
devant la Roumanie et ce n'est pas
l'essai de l'ER Gachassin marqué juste
avant la mi-temps qui aura changé quoi
que ce soit à l'opinion qu'on a de cette
équipe de France une équipe mal àroite
une équipe sans armes bref une équipe
sans capitaine manœvré le plus souvent
par les Roumains qui ne sont pourtant
pas des foudres de guerre et l'essai que
marque la Roumanie c'est un cadeau que
leur fait l'arrière français
r etess suivi d'un drop 6 à 3 pour les
R
malgré quelques réactions sporadiqu et
désordonné de l'équipe de France c'est
miracle si la Roumanie n'a pas marqué
d'autres points au cours de la parti et
c'est grâce à leur métier plus qu'à leur
qualité que les Français arrachent le
match nul par un essai de dupuie un
essai de très belle facture d'ailleurs
quoi qu'il en soit ce match
France-Roumanie est une dure déception
en tout cas un sévère avertissement pour
les
[Musique]
Français le général de Gaulle accompagné
du ministre de l'information Monsieur
perfit et de Monsieur Bordas directeur
général de la RTF a installé
officiellement la radio dans son palais
sans doute en effet n'y a-t-il pas
d'autres noms pour désigner le plus
grand bâtiment qui est été construit en
France depuis longtemps la dimension
d'une salle comme celle où allait se
dérouler sur trois écrans le spectacle
d'inauguration en Dyon sur cet édifice
sorte de colisé des temps modernes fait
d'aluminium de verre d'acier et de béton
qui a inscrit sa physionomie futuriste
dans le panorama parisien
après la littérature c'est maintenant le
cinéma qui vient de voir décerner ses
prix un jury a attribué au réalisateur
François leerrier Le Grand Prix du
cinéma français un prix créé il y a 29
ans sous l'égit de Louis
lumierre la comédienne Marie dubis elle
a reçu des mains de Pierre B le prix
Susanne bianetti décerné par les auteurs
de film per pradiier Roger dum et
quelques aut parmi ces devanciers dans
cette distinction était venu la félicité
avec Simon Signoret et Noël
[Musique]
Noël l'air spatiale a maintenant 6 ans
dans cette aventure des temps modernes
la France n'est pas restée à l'écart
puisque grâce à la station relais de
plemur budou elle a déjà pu participer
par le moyen des satellites à la
première transmission d'imag en direct
de à
Contin mais et ce fut la révélation du
Salon du Bourget elle a entrepris
elle-même de conquérir l'espace en
créant ses propres satellites et son
propre lance satellite le véhicule
[Musique]
diamant une fusée gigogne composée d'un
premier étage émeraude d'un second étage
Topaz et d'un 3e étage porteur d'un
satellite la réalisation minutieuse de
ce projet aujourd'hui assez avancé pour
que nous ayons pu lever le voile
émeraude le premier étage est une fusée
de 10 m dont les réservoirs peuvent
contenir 13 tonnes de carburant liquide
le moteur tout entier chambre de
combustion et tuère fixé par un système
articulé est
orientable sur le plus grand banc
d'essaiis statique d'Europe continentale
à Vernon ce premier étage a déjà subi
200 essais et dans le blocos souterrain
les techniciens ont pu déjà juger de ces
[Musique]
pendant 90 secondes la tuyère développe
une poussée continue de 30
tonnes le moteur du 2è étage Topaz qui
brûlera un bloc de poudre de 2 tonnes
est équipé de qu tuyères mobiles ce
dispositif permettra l'orientation de
l'étage dans toutes les directions en
fonction des ordres de
pilotage le fonctionnement des est ici
vérifié dans les conditions voisines de
celle du
[Musique]
vol pour le 3è étage les études de
résistance des métaux exposés à la
désagrégation ont conduit à une
conception
révolutionnaire une machine dont la
commande électronique prédétermine le
caneva de tissage a été mise au point
pour façonner une enveloppe en fibre de
verre enrobée de résine
synthétique un spectacle à faire rêver
toutes les fileuses du
[Musique]
monde une telle structure permett à
l'enveloppe de résister aux énormes
pressions de combustion de la poudre
aussi bien que le frais les aciers les
plus étudiés mais avec un poids qure
fois
moindre chargé de 650 kg de ce dernier
étage a été lui aussi essayé avec
[Musique]
succès la transparence des fibres de
verre a permis de suivre à travers le
fond du propulseur la combustion
progressive du bloc de
poudre mais la mise au point des trois
étages n'est pas tout parallèlement il a
fallu soumettre l'ensemble des
équipements et des matériels de mesure
montés sur diamant à ce qu'on nomme les
essais d'ambiance c'est-à-dire au
condition particulièr que le lancement
leur fera subir échauffement aussi bien
que
[Musique]
refroidissement on a ainsi reproduit en
laboratoire dans une série de caissons
les phénomènes qui se produiront pendant
le vol et parmi lesquels les phénomènes
vibratoires et acoustiques ne sont pas
des
[Musique]
moindres
la résistance au choc également a dû
être méthodiquement
testée mais aujourd'hui le but n'est
plus loin depuis 1 an Topaz le deè étage
a été lancé de nombreuses fois avec
succès et d'ors et déjà ce premier engin
balistique piloté français est en mesure
d'assurer son rôle dans le projet
diamant et dans la région parisienne on
a pu assister au montage des deux
premiers étages émerudde et Topaz qui
après avoir accompli séparément leurs
essais auront à les accomplir
[Musique]
ensemble et on peut imaginer le lance
satellite diamant tel qu'il apparaîtra
dans sa tour de lancement un jour de
1965 ce jour-là qui n'est plus lointain
il emportera le premier satellite qui
fera participer la France à la ronde
autour de la Terre
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]